[Music]
on this sunday night
a child's birthday party turns into a
crime scene
the young victims caught in the
crossfire in toronto
everybody was screaming everybody was
running it's disgusting and it hurts my
heart
what led to the shooting taking off the
masks
in saskatchewan is it too soon in the
next phase of reopening
the extreme weather in the u.s the heat
wave in the west
tornadoes and floods in the east plus
the sweet sustainability solution
turning plastic
into vanilla
[Music]
global national with robin gill
evening and thank you for joining us we
begin in canada's largest city where a
shooting
during a toddler's birthday party sent
three children to hospital
police are still trying to piece
together what happened and find the
people responsible for this reckless
behavior
the community is in shock and calling
for action
catherine ward has our top story tonight
this is a horrific horrific situation
it could have been worse they could
there could be three dead children
a birthday party on a warm evening with
balloons and bouncy castles the night
before father's day
it's disgusting they have no respect and
it hurts my heart like
i couldn't even sleep last night to you
know to just think about like how
someone
could actually come at a one-year-old
birthday party and
do this toronto police say shots were
fired just before 8pm saturday
hitting a one-year-old boy a
five-year-old girl
and an 11-year-old boy as well as a 23
year old man
it was horrific you know you're seeing
lights
it's a disarray everybody's confused you
don't know who's who you don't know who
got shot because by that time it outside
is getting dark
it's hurtful emeline redhead says she
had just stepped inside the house when
the chaos started everybody was
screaming everybody was running
my son had just like he as i said we
walked out of the house
so he was in front of me and when i
heard it i screamed and i told him stop
and then i tell him get in the house she
was one of several people who comforted
the injured girl who was also
a friend to her son saying you're ok
you're going to be ok we're just waiting
for the ambulance just stay awake ok
people in the community tell global news
the five-year-old had surgery this
morning
and the one-year-old has been released
from hospital police have yet to confirm
those details
no word on the other victims much of
sunday was spent gathering evidence
and reviewing security footage as the
crime scene expanded
police say they are looking for multiple
suspects but have not released any
descriptions
and while toronto's mayor and ontario's
premier issued messages of support
advocates say more needs to be done they
were talking about
proper representation people listening
to them when they call the office they
need proper response they don't
like promises not kept they're sick and
tired of
tired of the violence and tired of
innocent children
getting caught in the middle catherine
ward global news
toronto turning now to the pandemic
saskatchewan moves into a new phase of
reopening today
the province is lifting many of the
pandemic restrictions that have been in
place for months
and because it also reached an important
vaccination threshold
the stage has been set for dropping
masks in july
global's roberta bell reports so i think
that's what's going to
be our guiding light for reopening
saskatchewan's chief medical health
officer is referring to vaccine
now that 69 of the eligible population
over the age of 12 has received a first
dose
the premier has announced all provincial
public health orders
including the mask mandate will be
lifted on july 11.
because so many of you have already done
your part you have gotten your shot we
can safely move forward with reopening
and removing the public health orders
meanwhile saskatchewan has already moved
into step two of its plan
regina residents were making the most of
the relaxed restrictions
responsibly on sunday i'm pretty excited
because it's been a long time coming now
probably just plate safe for now but
it's nice to see things open i guess
i'm feeling comfortable about it
restaurants like retailers can now
operate without capacity limits but
physical distancing must be maintained
this just gives us that flexibility back
allows us
the customers to be happy and us to be
happy
another big change a maximum of 150
people will be allowed at casinos
theaters and private outdoor gatherings
and up to 15 people can gather at
private indoor gatherings
both outdoor and indoor recreational
sports are back on
at some point we need to develop the
confidence of living
living with kowitt the province's chief
medical health officer says although
saskatchewan is reopening
officials will be continuing to monitor
case numbers and hospitalizations
roberta bell global news regina
brazil's death toll from covid 19 has
surpassed half a million
today activists set up this display at
rio de rio de janeiro's world-famous
copacabana beach to draw attention to
the deaths
500 red roses were installed in memory
of those who have died since the
pandemic began
it's also intended to rebuke the
president's attempts to minimize the
devastating
impact of kova 19. and as mike delay
explains
there are fears the situation in south
america's largest country
is going to get worse before it gets
better
they call it the beautiful game if
there's one thing that unites brazilians
it's football yet the crowds in over 300
cities weren't screaming for goals
they want vaccines says this teacher who
lives just outside rio de janeiro
no one's watching it i don't think i
don't think brazilians are
are watching it we're not paying
attention to it
for the first time ever brazilians have
other things on their minds
this weekend the country surpassed 500
000 covet 19 deaths
the second highest death toll after the
u.s and many are placing the blame
solely on the shoulders
of president jair bolsonaro
we can't stand it anymore says this
demonstrator the government is worse
than the virus
bolsonaro has called kovid the little
flu discouraged lockdowns and masks
and dismissed vaccines
the government's plan was to reach herd
immunity says his former health official
they did not buy vaccines because they
did not believe they worked
bolsonaro now says that's not true but
an ongoing parliamentary inquiry found
the government ignored
81 emails from pfizer offering vaccines
at half the price offered to the u.s
i don't have any anger anymore you know
that's how angry i am
i don't i don't even feel anymore
because there's so many people
who who are dead branca bajos feels
lucky to have received her first dose of
the vaccine
but with only 29 percent of brazilians
in the same boat
health experts don't expect to see a
drop in covid cases
until at least september microlight
global news toronto
a member of uganda's olympic team tested
positive for kova 19 upon entering japan
this is the first positive test for an
arriving athlete ahead of the games
he's been quarantined at a government
government-designated facility
the ugandan team was fully vaccinated
with astrazeneca and had negative pcr
tests before boarding the flight
this comes just hours before olympic
organizers are set to decide if
local fans will be loud in the stands
the tokyo olympics open
july 23rd china has reached a major
vaccination milestone
the country has administered more than a
billion covid19 vaccine doses
that's more than a third of all shots
given globally china's vaccination drive
started slowly but concerns over the
delta variant have forced the campaign
to pick up several vaccines are being
used in china but only two
sinopharm and sinovac have been cleared
for use by the world health organization
the kova 19 pandemic put additional
strain on all facets of the health care
system in this country
physician assistance an emerging
profession could ease the burden
doctors hospital managers and
universities all agree
that canada needs more of these
positions but as ross lord explains
those calls have so far gone unanswered
among the cracks in the health care
system revealed by covert 19
is a shortage of professionals often
overlooked
physician assistants the urgency this
year has been really amplified
because of the pandemic ten years after
the first physician assistance graduated
from canadian universities
there are fewer than 800 in the entire
country
those on the front lines and healthcare
managers
want more more physicians more employers
reaching out saying we just want to hire
a pa
and we essentially have to say you know
you're you need to wait for the next
class of graduates because there just
isn't any movement right now the number
of postings
is outnumbering the number of graduates
at ontario's mcmaster university
applications for the two-year program
starting this coming september
reached the 1200 mark unfortunately the
vast majority of those students are out
of luck
because they're competing for only 24
classroom positions
we have been trying to make the case to
governments across the country
to increase those training spots but
progress has been slow
in spite of endorsements from other
professional groups like the canadian
medical association
physician assistants are not a big drain
on health care budgets they're paid
far less than the doctors who supervise
them
complete patient history taking so
understanding a patient's complaint and
why they're there to see us that day we
perform
advanced physical examinations we can
order and we can interpret
medical investigations we can diagnose
their profession
is developing more provinces are
regulating physician assistance to
clarify their scope of practice
but with only 70 pas being trained per
year at four
universities they'll have a limited
impact in clearing
up pandemic backlogs in hospitals and
reducing waiting lists for family
doctors
ross lord global news coming up from
droughts in the west to storms in the
east
we have you covered on the weather
situation down south
[Music]
across the u.s tens of millions of
americans are facing
extreme weather the remnants of tropical
storm claudette are soaking the
southeast
after flooding gulf states and spawning
a tornado in the west a blistering heat
wave and sweltering temperatures are
hanging over
drought-ravaged areas and as jennifer
johnson reports
it's all setting the stage for a summer
of dangerous weather
80 kilometer an hour winds and
relentless rain hit alabama louisiana
and the florida panhandle
as tropical storm claudette slammed into
the southeast
the storm also triggered multiple
tornadoes all of a sudden the trees
kind of just it was just like they
imploded
and brewton alabama trucks ended up on
houses
at least 50 structures were destroyed
the entire roof was ripped off this high
school auditorium
we're in recovery efforts now just
trying to make sure we've cleared all
the residents
make sure there's no one in there other
areas were spared the twisters but were
hit with massive flooding
ten people including nine children were
killed in a multi-vehicle crash in
alabama
the coroner says the accident was likely
caused by hydroplaning on wet roads
the national transportation safety board
is investigating
while parts of the east are drenched
parts of the west are desperate for rain
tens of millions of people are under
extreme heat advisories
it's exhausting it's kind of draining
temperatures from missouri to california
are shattering daily records
residents and workers are doing
everything they can to beat the heat
we try to get out there about seven
eight o'clock you know to cut us a few
hours from from dealing with the sun
the environmental protection agency says
america is suffering more
intense heat waves every year and
they're starting earlier each year
paramedics in dallas have been swamped
with calls
anyone in the city who's working
outdoors not in a climate controlled
environment is absolutely at risk
for heat stroke or heat exhaustion the
las vegas strip hit a scorching 45
degrees celsius
shattering an 81-year record in
california residents are being asked to
voluntarily conserve power
not use major appliances and unplug
anything they can
as storing temperatures force power
companies to conduct
rolling blackouts we have fans and
that's all we just keep the
windows open and we try to have that
across air with no rain and high heat
california is once again dealing with
wildfires
i got a text message from a friend
saying that there was going to be
an evacuation we need to get out of here
federal experts say more mega heat waves
are on their way
the national weather service predicts
most of the country will experience
above average temperatures over the next
three months
making it a more dangerous summer than
normal jennifer johnson global news
washington still ahead could the
solution to the shortage of vanilla
be found in recycled bottles
you're watching global national
it's the first day of summer and with
the weather warming up you may find
yourself reaching for a beverage
in a plastic bottle it's a convenience
we've all grown accustomed to despite
its huge toll on the environment
it's estimated the world will produce
more than half a trillion plastic
bottles this year
it takes between 450 years to a thousand
years for each bottle to decompose
but researchers in scotland may have
found a new high value
product that can come from upcycling
bottles
into vanilla flavoring redmond shannon
has a surprising scoop
water water everywhere the world is
addicted to the convenience of plastic
bottles
a 2017 study estimated that a million
single-use bottles are sold worldwide
every minute it's thought only one in
seven are recycled
mostly to make fabric or other plastics
but in our disposable economy
it's usually cheaper and easier to just
dump them
and make new ones researchers in
scotland have potentially found a
valuable use for
some of that waste in the most
unexpected of places
in plain old vanilla so i put my
chemistry hat on and
looked at the molecules that actually
make plastic and
thought well what could we turn that
into that would be more valuable than
the waste plastic
and i came up with vanillin because it's
such an important molecule
vanillin is the molecule that gives
natural vanilla its taste
the huge demand to use it in foods
cosmetics and
pharmaceuticals outstrips the global
crop
so it's usually synthesized from
petrochemicals
but never before from plastic waste
scientists used enzymes to break down
the plastic polymer
into what are called monomer molecules
namely pterophthalic acid
they then used engineered e coli
bacteria
to turn the monomer into a vanillin
molecule the whole process takes about
three days i think one bottle would give
you enough for
baking a cake more than enough probably
enough for a cake sale
what we now need to do is develop it
further and do more studies
to optimize the process and scale it up
and find ways to
extract very pure samples of manila such
that it is safe
for consumers it's potentially a win-win
solution
according to an industry body focused on
a circular economy for plastics
what was super interesting about this
example was that it's very in
in some ways upcycling so it's
increasing the value a big part of
the work that we're doing
collaboratively is to figure out how do
you make that recycling system and that
recirculation system
as efficient as possible and optimized
as possible so that it economically does
make sense
but until our sundays are made from old
soda bottles
the best bet will be to reduce and reuse
redmond shannon global news london
well said redmond just in time for
father's day meghan markle the duchess
of sussex has released a children's book
it's called the bench named after the
gift she gave her husband prince harry
for his first father's day after the
birth of their son archie
the illustrated book features diverse
depictions of fathers and sons
the duchess spoke to national public
radio in the united states about the
book
she describes it as a love story that
aims to represent
all kinds of families
so any child or any family hopefully can
open this book and see themselves in it
whether that means
glasses or freckled or a different body
shape or different ethnicity
or religion i mean even the military
family
earlier this month megan and harry
welcomed their second child
daughter lilibet diana up next how one
dad stepped up for his wife and new
daughter
in the face of a life-changing illness
the city of moncton held its annual
three fathers memorial run
in memory of the three mounties killed
in 2014.
the event was mostly virtual this year
it invited anyone across canada to run
or walk
with proceeds going to school bursaries
constables fablice javodan
dave ross and doug larch were murdered
when an armed man went on a shooting
spree
targeting police officers
today is a meaningful day that
me and my children get to gather and
remember
their dad and it's just beautiful to see
the community
come together once again this year to to
honor and remember doug dave and fabrice
on this father's day many of you are
honoring the father figures in your
lives
but for one toronto family every day has
special meaning
when r.j polowski became a new dad he
didn't just have to care for his
daughter
his wife was diagnosed with a
life-changing illness
and that changed all of their lives
here's morgan campbell
how do you feel daddy terrified this
moment is likely one
many dads can relate to that first car
ride home
from the hospital all we gotta do is get
this one home but what you don't know
is the painful and challenging road this
couple endured
just to get to this very moment she was
growing
and i was breaking i was breaking apart
i could i couldn't move i couldn't walk
it was terrifying
it really was because i didn't know if i
was equipped to be able to deal with
all of those things as rj pulaski and
his wife take in the sunshine on the
back deck of their toronto home
there is a lot to be thankful for in the
summer of 2019
margaret received the best and worst
news possible
she was pregnant but one day later the
doctor found a lump on her breast
it was cancer and it spread throughout
her spine breaking vertebraes and ribs
not long after she would learn her
cancer was metastatic
i was just able to take things one day
at a time and just like okay
i'm here i'm here another day from worse
the worst the worst the worst to worse
and i think it was a lot of unknowns
another thing the couple didn't plan for
was marianna's early arrival
she was born at just 27 weeks at that
moment
r.j had a wife who was still undergoing
cancer treatments
and a baby in the neonatal intensive
care unit
at mount sinai hospital r.j quickly
graduated from husband to father
and began caring for both girls being
present
in those moments is the most important
thing
for for me for my time with my daughter
and my time with my wife
time that is limited margaret's cancer
is stable at the moment but the
prognosis
isn't good marianna is 17 months old now
and developing well
they spend every waking moment making
memories as a family
in isolation marianna choose hope
as something better for the future for
the next day for the next moment for the
next hour
i really do believe we did that like we
we did it and we're doing it and you can
see that hope when you watch this little
family of three
interact with each other it is a
reminder that hope
is a powerful thing morgan campbell
global news
toronto and that is global national for
this sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is sunset beach in
vancouver
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and i'll see you next weekend
have a great night
[Music]
you